let's start so yeah we are going to talk
you first about the split up then about
some things we had two night train to to
extend the possibility for training then
also parameterised net model which are
kind of factories of a network which are
not in his rise like let more than up to
now - it was a pre train model already
trained model and now we extended the
ability to to add some parameters then
we talked about the new layers that we
did so we extended some existing layers
and added new ones to be able to
implement the state-of-the-art
architectures like capsule networks and
transformer and finally we've talked
about byte / encoding which is a hot
stuff for translation so first we gained
some some speed up for our errand end on
CPU so for example this command which
used to take half a second in Russian
11.3 now yeah it's taking it's a five
five times faster so I ran a much faster
on CPU also now that way there will be
the possibility of doing Moochie GPU
like before you could do target device
go to CPU or GPU and if you had several
GPU you can specify which GPU you want
to use and now if you put all then you
could do a multi GPU and not very fast
training then also we are supporting
pencil core which is a special
architecture of GPU which are which are
doing very fast magic multiplications so
it's for its working in mixed precision
16 and 32 bytes and for example here we
see the benchmark on on speed up on some
classical architectures so you see that
it can be a three times faster on
visionary for example and so yeah it's
it's a big speed up for convolution and
also icon down networks
everything that involve a matrix
multiplications also we are supporting
numeric arrays so I think there is a
presentation right now on numeric array
which is a new format to
to represent in a compact form
mattresses rather than having lists of
lists so we are supporting this an
America if you do normally just matrix
and also with the option working
precision you can choose to work in
either 32 or 64 bits so now it's making
the non networks a scientific framework
it's a much more efficient and you can
choose your the precision that you want
for computations if you gather way
around yes
no network supports in America right so
you will be able to send America right
directly into it and to do some
computations because in no networks were
operation that I'm not necessarily in
Mathematica so it can be convenient also
to to use it to handle numeric array yes
because it's more compact I mean the
numeric arrays are like bringing like C
style typed arrays into into top level
as a first-class citizen of the language
and so it has some advantages yeah but
you can specify the type you can have
integers and in one spot okay now let's
see what we serve the main advantage is
is usually memory because prior to this
all fourteen point numbers in top-level
lists were only 64 bits and that's it
well in deep learning usually you
usually don't want to go above 42 so so
so you get lots of memory yeah I mean
you get much less memory usage and not
so for example for integers like for
semantic segmentation which is you just
classify every pixel you have these
masks in which for every pixel you have
an integer which tells you what class
does it belong and also prior to that
every single one of those integers were
64 bits so while you can as long as you
have less than 256 passes you can do
with 8 bits so that's that's I mean you
get a lot into memory consumption so now
let's see what we added the two met
train in order to do is there to make me
tryna get a higher level more higher
level function so so yeah this is not
fully implemented yet but we will have
this option training measurements where
it's like classify our measurements like
you can there is a full list of modules
that you can that you can have for
classification like F 1 we call
precision also micro eco micro precision
for those who are familiar with this
kind of modules so basically all the all
the things that are in pacifier
measurement are going to be there so so
for now it's not plotting where it's not
protein yet when I'm training but here
we should have the the curls of the
recall the precision and the for f1
score here yeah but if I stop it just to
show that it's then it's one of the
output probability that you can you can
ask for the validation measurements to
all the modules that you ask also will
be there like for your final net and you
can also ask the values on the training
set it's called the run measurements so
you say here is for each class the
recall and the precision because it's
built a class classification here is
fashion M list which is small images of
fashions and you have ten classes and so
yeah you've got the classification
measure for all the classes also early
stopping so early stopping is very
useful when you perform long training
and you don't want to monitor it today
to see where is your training so you
want to to stop automatically where the
network stops improving on the
validation set so that so
is an option now a training stopping
criterion so I can be more so I have
some some data like this and here for
example I asked to to stop when the
error rate is not improving for 50
rounds so we can check here and yeah
it's the minimum is around here do you
see my mouth say the minimum is around
here and then we stopped five five
rounds after so we can also specify a
loss and there is more parameter like
instead of talking about strictly in two
months you can say okay let's stop when
the relative improvement is less than
than the ratio and then it will it will
take this into a control zone okay there
are also some new properties so I remind
that the third argument of net train you
can ask properties by default is the
train network which you can ask for the
outer classification materials or the
loss during the training and now you can
specify some Association like this and
here for example I'm going to ask for
for the The Bachelor C's I want you to
ask for plot of this and to sample its
every batch and I can also ask for the
root-mean-square of the gradients so it
can be it can is the debugging like if
you run short training incident is
diverging and maybe it's on a particular
batch for example when there is a normal
cycle sequence then with this kind of
plots you will be able to detect
anomalies this kind of stuff so this
kind of activities for for the burly
okay so we also unlock the possibility
of doing a reinforcement learning and
active learning all this kind of stuff
so yeah we integrated the opening items
so as to do some proof of concept of
reinforcement learning so it's using
device
open to do it so yeah reinforcement
learning basically as a net is giving
some policy to take some the next action
given the state so all the previous
action that was taken and so the
particularities that you need or evalso
the environment is your data but it
needs to interact with your network like
this better this is going to comment at
the next round depends on what what
happened before and what answer the
network so you need a ids feedback
between the network and the data and so
basically the unlocking consists in
giving access in the data generator so
we could I remember that in net rain you
can give some that are pre-loaded in
memory like are raised goes to Liddell's
but you can also build the data
regeneration which is a function that
generates your data and now inside this
data generation you will be to access
some properties of the training
including the network and here I do so
yeah there will be some tutorial soon on
the reinforcement learning to explain
how to do it and here are I I restore
demo and other stuff which is a active
learning so active learning it's when
you you you want to split the training
and then to to to focus on the examples
that are hard like if you if you see
that you are classifying well and one
examples then you are going to down
raise them so what i'm doing here i'm i
define the data generator which is
partitioning the data into batches and
then by default as a assigning equal
weights to all the data and then i'm
going to access in my data generation
the bachelors and which is the cross
entropy and depending on this content
appear I will give some weights for to
sample to sample the the next data to
give to the network and to check that it
works also here I'm appending into a
list
dispatch close and and so you didn't see
each training sorry no we are more for
looking at the state of the art at the
last papers and when the Academy also
like do the novelties come from the
Academy so for example now in deep
learning range shows fun turning and
against generative and result
non networks are very hot so this kind
of stuff
here when we see that a when we judge
that many people are using it then the
post-processing are inside the network
or I would say that we follow the
literature for the to look at the
applications that we actually need to
support but then they design to actually
build the tools to support this
application is genuine because our
framework is a much higher level than
other frameworks so I mean it's its goal
is to be easier to use and you don't
have to write you usually have to write
like much less code so just start in our
frame or not in other frameworks and so
like the design in which we we we
actually come up with how to add these
tools you know frameworks is mostly
original because our framework is very
different from from from from other
frameworks usually like for example
those training measurements in the Train
like basically no other framework has
not trained except for carrots so it's
this is an example of the promote be
much higher
yeah
yes further sorry yes but yes we use a
mechs neck in the backend but our
framework does doesn't look anything
like a mixed nuts I mean it's you can
see the entire framework as a very
sophisticated wrapper over Alex Nets but
IMAX net is completely hidden like all
the complexity of dealing with a max net
it's it's much simpler to use so all the
design is we are in principal for the
layoffs prison maybe he meant we could
swap the backend with something else in
principle yes but it requirements of
work but in principle yes yes yes we we
make we make we contribute yes
so permit ResNet models so the initial
motivation for these was that we already
have many models in the neural network
repository which belong to the same
family okay so for example there are
three resonant resonate models trained
an image at the original resident models
so it would make sense to add something
like this wouldn't you call net model a
brass nuts type goes to whatever so this
is this is how it was built and it will
many parametrize net models coming from
12 these are some of them so we get okay
I will actually well in principle I
would have demoed this thing but I will
just show you screenshot this running
okay these are some example of some
parameterize net models which are coming
in the repository for 12 so the first
example will be sketch RM so sketch your
name is a that's actually okay this was
supposed to be a loosely I think we all
the time you can yeah okay fine so let's
look at one of the first
parameterizing that models wait a second
no there are more okay there are more
screenshots okay fine yeah okay so this
was example two of parameterize let's
start memorizing Network so so sketch
our name was something like you have a
family of models like like resonate or
show you before and you can pick a
particular pre-trained one but the the
parameterize model paradigm allows you
also to basically generate architecture
on the fly what is a plume here it's
going worse and worse okay fine like
this so you can pick individual
pre-trained models with a
parameterization pair like but you can
also generate architecture on the fly
with privatization paradigm so this is
out the API for deprioritize would look
like so the cell unit is the cell for
normalizing nets this is an
uninitialized model in it's basically a
factory of architectures okay so there
are parameters here yet depth and width
you can query these parameters
information which are data set with all
descriptions and you can generate this
architecture on the fly with calls to
the private right and one is in this way
so you get first argument is the name of
the model and lining up all the
specification for the parameters and
boom you get the video net change so
this would be an exchange with that five
of we 32 with report probability of 0.3
and you'll also get defaults and so on
so yeah so this makes for the
parameterize and API so should i do BP
or should you lots probably you should
you should keep doing okay that's nice
yes yes it will be in the repository
well well well 12 goes live the model
will show up on the repository
yes yes it will be fully available okay
so now we also had some extension and
improvement of existing layers so for
instance reshape layer will now accept
the automatics and in Irbid
specification so with so reshape layer
is as you have guessed it will shape
something put and sort of some target
shape just like Irish it does so we have
now added the automatic and inherited
keywords in aspects so automatics will
infer a single dimension from the
product of the others so as to keep the
same size and hinari didn't just copy
the dimension so for example here I can
specify to copy the first dimension
which is varying so still variable
length and and and I can infer this
automatically and I specify this to be
two and so the automatic will generate
correctly a four here so as to much they
are very useful because they will fully
integrate with our
reshaping engine which is done from that
replaced part and changing the input
shape so previously if you get something
like this which which would output the
size of 8 by 3 by 2 and then you change
the input size you would get a mismatch
between the product of the dimensions of
input and output anything just fail but
when using automatic and inherited it
will just work and reevaluate itself so
this variant me to change the input size
of the networks which is misshaped layer
insider so I made an improvement to
convolution the convolutional pooling so
we have so we are finally supporting the
so-called grouped convolutions with
parameters so this was an old
functionality that's old for hist
originally appearing in cafe sure these
mainly introduced by alex nets in order
to overcome GPU memory limitations but
now it has risen back to popularity
because you sacrifice some
expressiveness
but but you get much faster evaluation
time and so there is this very popular
architecture which is coming as a prize
model by the way which is called mobile
nets which is very which is a
lightweight convolutional network which
uses this and so now we can specify the
channel groups both in convolution um
Boosh then well other minor things like
one dimension of the convolutions and a
symmetric padding specification so
previously we could do a symmetric
padding by using padding layer but now
it's also build team in the framework so
this means pad by three zeros on the
left of axis 1 1 0 and the right about
this one and so on and so forth and this
is pulling segregated with also the
variable length support and interleaved
convolution which being the channel
dimension at the last so it's it's it's
a nice addition okay so caption it but
this probably no more time imma show you
ok fine there was a lots of new stuff in
the framework and it's hot stuff
proposed proposed by intern like a new
product in the neural network so yeah we
were missing yeah some kind of pieces
like in 11.3 it's available with but
with MX layer which can affect to to do
some MX MX dead coding inside the layers
so we don't don't need it anymore and
also a hot stuff is a transformers which
is for translation like now it's the
state-of-the-art Fortran or the
translation models use it and it's not
based on like on our network so an STM
has existed for 10 years and it will
know architecture as we did it and here
it's it's a new architecture based on
attention so I don't have to time to
explain but we already add a
attention layer that was there and and
we extended it to be able to implement
the Transformers with some yes oh so
there is an attention layer and also the
layer normalization layer normalization
yeah we are the layer called instance
normalization before which was doing
this stuff here and now you are able to
do layer normalization so a is called
normalization layer and with lot of
parameters you can it originally become
a general layer which which which can
reproduce instant summarization and book
and also batch of meditation I think
that is that is coming but yeah it's
it's a big generalization of it as
summarization yeah exactly
so now there are pre-trained the
transformer that are going to be also in
the video and also for the encoding part
so we wanted to talk with from the time
about VPN coding which is a kind of
tokenization that groups
tokenized in some words you know the
state of the art for translation so
sorry about the overtime and the issue
thank you
[Applause]